it's a crippling time for american
consumers
the inflation rate hovering around a
four decade high of nine percent the
base interest at which money is lent
increased four times this year already
and now the news that the gdp has shrunk
for the second quarter another blow to
national confidence although president
biden insists the economy will recover
and there is no recession
both chairman powell
and many of the uh
significant uh
banking personnel and economists
say we're not in recession the biden
administration points to the fact that
employment is rising at an unprecedented
rate with over two and a half million
new jobs created this year alone as
clear evidence that it's doing a good
job
an opinion echoed by the treasury
secretary
most economists and most americans
have a similar definition of recession
substantial job losses and mass layoffs
businesses shutting down
private sector activities slowing
considerably
family budgets under immense strain in
some a broad-based weakening of our
economy
that is not what we're seeing right now
but many republicans in a divided
congress are seeing a political
opportunity
well aware that should the november
elections take place in the shadow of a
recession it would be devastating for
the administration in power this economy
is not working well you know economists
are going to argue about whether we're
in recession or not but those are
academic debates in order to
de-politicize the term it's an
independent body which decides whether
or not a recession is underway
the national bureau of economic research
consists of eight economists who gather
and examine all relevant data and then
make an independent determination
polls indicate that some 50 percent of
the us population believes the recession
has already begun
despite what the president says there's
going to be a lot of chatter today on
wall street and among pundits about
whether we are in a recession
and in a meeting with president biden a
number of chief executive officers agree
there is no recession
pointing to the notable absence of the
most historically reliable sign of a
downturn
a half point rise in the unemployment
rate averaged over several months
mike hanna al jazeera washington